[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the la hile
pan show powered by icon plus capital
the visa the vc firm and sponsored by
blockfi you can get 250 when you sign up
if you find the link somewhere and
everywhere joining me today is ben
askren ben how you doing
i'm doing good i'm just on vacation with
my family right now we're in northern
wisconsin so i did this yesterday the
internet worked i'm hoping it works
again i'm a little bit nervous but uh
let's do it no i think it's gonna be
good i watched your show yesterday um
and you had a pretty interesting chat so
i'm gonna push you on a few things
let's go
yeah i'm excited but it's been i think
nearly a year since we last spoke you
were the third guest on my podcast
um
so i feel like it's quite it's quite um
like poetic you know like doing it a
year later
yeah absolutely i i'm gonna say we're
gonna have you back on our show because
uh you got a book coming out so i'm
excited to
read that and then we'll have to have
you on and chat about your book
yeah no i'm honestly so bad but what
have you been up to since we last spoke
i know you were working on a couple
different things i think you launched um
you launched a course like a year ago
but what are you working on at the
moment
uh man i got my main thing with my
wrestling academy is we have five of
them in the state of wisconsin here um
for those of you who don't know that's
like north of chicago uh for you people
in the uk
my main my my main focus uh we also have
podcasts so i podcast flow wrestling we
do the crypto show on tuesdays
uh and like i said right now i'm on a
family vacation so everything's good
and last time we spoke you were saying
how you were helping people get into
crypto by sort of giving like paying
them in bitcoin to kind of
give you know so they don't have to buy
it how's that going especially the
wrestling academy have you been able to
get more people involved oh
the kids so it was it was the guys who
worked at my house last summer and then
oh yeah
they love me because they're all college
kids and you know so they made like
we'll say they made 800 a thousand bucks
but i paid them a bitcoin so you know at
that point it was i don't know we'll say
somewhere between
eight nine thousand dollars likely you
know we're talking july june july 2020.
um so most those guys made like seven
thousand dollars or six thousand dollars
you know for them they were really
pumped
that is amazing that is amazing what
about the wrestling academy are you able
to get anyone else involved
no i didn't pay anything with bitcoin
because i'm not the sole owner there uh
but it was mostly just those guys you
know what's really funny i i know you
talk a lot about crypto layout i got
one i think only one person to buy under
the old all-time high of twenty thousand
dollars uh i why i convinced one person
to buy it like
march 13 march 14 when the when the
crash happened in 2020
and then after 20 thousand dollars i
probably had 12 to 15 people buy and
it's like none of that it was just they
were just so scared before 20 000.
they're oh it's only 8 10
whatever and then after that there's
been a lot they've bought um
most of them are still in the green
because most of them bought you know
once a hit they're like oh this is safe
and they bought it say between 25 and
30. uh but i did have some friends buy
it you know 45.50 and then obviously you
know the dip happened they got nervous
and now they've been on the first roller
coaster ride so i think they're going to
be in for good
see they didn't panic sell
uh if they did they didn't admit it to
me
fair enough but you know what gets me so
there are so many really cool things in
this space whether it be just you know
like making gains you know hedging
against inflation but like so many cool
products like bitcoin cashback for
example like i use coin coin in coin
corner in the uk
and i'm trying to get my personal
trainer to
um start using these things
and she won't do it like i don't
understand why people just won't do it
it's so life-changing you could just
like get eight percent you know cash
back even you know whether it's
crypto.com when you use these cards
people are so afraid like they think
it's too good to be true do you find
that yeah
uh
hmm i think it's more just uh
people are scared of change people are
scared of something new our thought it
requires them to learn something so i
also
i have gotten my i haven't put this out
but i got my block fight card also
oh
it's great i get cash back
um i've put some of the crypto over
there to kind of try it out i'm playing
with uniswap now that's kind of scary
because that i still don't totally get
it i
starting to get it uh but that's hard
yeah so there's a lot of these
mechanisms in crypto right now uh who
rewards you like i guess we'll say like
banks used to reward you right if we go
uh 50 uh 80 100 years back banks
actually rewarded their savers and now
banks don't reward their savers i think
the interest rate on a savings account
is like point
zero five percent or something just it's
not something i i know i had someone
call me from a bank recently and because
i don't know why they shouldn't have
access but they saw that i had a large
balance and they said well you shouldn't
put in a checking account you should put
a savings account i said what what's the
interest they said it's like point zero
point six or something i'm like well you
realize how like nothing that is
did you wait you said that to them
it's nothing i don't care i don't i
don't need your point six percent or
whatever [ __ ] you're trying to give
me like if you were gonna give me five
percent i'd consider but you're not so
get lost
what did they say when you said that
i think i think it was very short
conversation they didn't have anything
else just you know when you're when
you're giving a sales pitch on something
you want to be able to you know fill the
customer's questions
and when i say don't you have anything
better than point six percent or maybe
it was even it might have even been less
than that it might have been like point
four i don't recall exactly um they
didn't have anything else better to
offer so i should not get lost you know
yeah good it's negative interest rates
across europe so yeah this is why i say
to people you know get involved and they
just don't do it um
but it's been a crazy week with the
markets um i know you mainly talk about
bitcoin but i really just want to delve
into this and understand
you know
how diversified
you really are
um you retweeted my ada yeah you
retweeted my ada tweet the are you are
you an ada holder
i bought ada at eight cents
ain't good to me
did you buy like a good amount is it are
you is it life changing now
i wouldn't say it's very nice i wouldn't
say life changing um but yeah it's a
good amount um the other thing is that
you're really nice about ada and i
didn't really so i bought it on etoro
when i was working with them and uh they
just stake it for me so i've been
getting like
i don't know for a long time 50 60 more
eta per month or somewhere in there you
know so now it's like it's you know i
probably got a thousand two thousand i
don't say free ada but like that i
didn't buy right
it's free essentially right i staked it
and they gave me more so
um yes that's really nice
what else are you holding
um but you know what i just bought
on john
kim's advice
uh we've had tyler on the show a couple
times he's really really smart
um i and so you know i said hey you know
what john i trust you let's go for it i
bought some of that
uh i've had eth for a very long time
i've had litecoin for a very long time i
i told you this i got burned in 2017
because i bought some of the like [ __ ]
coin icos then with the zero so i have
tried to be more diligent about what i
invested and the majority of this it
varies
probably 80 bitcoin 70 bitcoin something
like that but like hey i'll throw a
couple thousand dollars on here five
thousand dollars on there just for fun
just see how it goes and um you know a
couple of them have done really well
what did you i remember you saying that
you had a really rocky ride in 2017
was it like 50k
you lost or something remind me oh
probably not so i probably put in and
probably the end of 2017 i probably put
in around fifty thousand dollars um
because at that point point basically
allowed me to put in like it was
something ridiculous it was only like
four thousand dollars a week so i have
to wait till actually
at that point if you remember it was
going on everything was going like this
you know so it's like if i could have
got it in in august versus probably took
me until november or something to get it
in it would have been much nicer
i just i didn't buy enough bitcoin right
i bought bitcoin i bought my coin i
bought ethereum but then i bought a
bunch that went to zero i bought um
oh veritasium went to zero
uh pillar is close to zero or something
out of it
zero
so yeah so i did i probably lost we
would let's say between twelve and
twenty thousand dollars on projects that
went to zero that's probably a fair
guess so how are you picking your
projects now other than john kim's uh
recommendation
majority of it's bitcoin um yeah you
know i think that's now been established
and when i tell new people to get into
it i just just buy bitcoin it's simple
it's been around forever it's safe
it's safe and it still has some pretty
good upside
um
and then you know a lot of it i bought
luckily i had a bunch of cash sitting
around in
march of 2020 when everything went down
you know still like
i got a theorem at 170 i got ate at
eight cents you know i bought a lot of
these projects when everything because i
was i've been following them at that
point and then this crash happened and
i'm like oh crap like
we're never gonna see pro my thing was
we're never going to see prices this low
this is like
the lordness and i think
i believe that has been true with almost
everything so i bought a lot of things
back then so
yeah i guess in 2021
i would say it's like bitcoin um i
bought a tiny bit of uni unit swap and
link just for fun
well i think those categories are like
there is going to be a d5 exchange
that's going to be
totally insanely huge
right and unisoft leading the way
there's going to be an oracle that's
totally insanely huge and
do you ever get um you're obviously
quite diversified so do you ever get
wrapped up in like bitcoin maximalism or
like
you just like brush that stuff off you
know
i just i
i mean
i know the a lot of people do bitcoin i
know they're really smart i know they're
really really
and i know as far as
uh
crypto they were they had more knowledge
than me 100 of that
but just the fact that there could only
be one i i don't get it and the other
thing about that is you only need to
have one counter example to prove them
wrong
because once they're wrong they're wrong
you know and they so like i just don't
see
and i know a few of them kind of got on
me but i i don't see how you can
accomplish some of the things that these
other products accomplish with just
bitcoin i just don't feel like it can be
done um and you know the one i that i've
worked a lot with is the ray token which
is a very small project at this point um
but it supplies the rockford network and
essentially the raid token represents
the value of the rockfin network and if
you were to put bitcoin in place it just
wouldn't have the same effect so i just
don't get the bitcoin maximalism
yeah like here's my thing i i look at it
as like social media networks they're
all sort of the same
you know like you connect you speak to
people you can post pictures you can
write things but then they're not the
same and i don't really think it matters
whether we have multiple ones
you can still argue you know bitcoin is
the best store of value bitcoin is the
best technology
doesn't mean the others can't exist
yes
but it doesn't mean the others can't
exist
correct and then one thing that i would
say if they said just this very specific
thing
um i can agree i think i can agree with
it or again with it more is that bitcoin
is the only one that actually needs to
be a currency right so like ethereum can
be a token that works that network so
can cardano so can rate right these
other ones they can be a token that
represents things within that network um
that don't necessarily we need to be
dollars right we need to be currently um
whereas bitcoin i think bitcoin is now i
tell everyone to be that it's gonna be
the greatest currency humans have ever
invented
no i'm with you like to me
this time that always gets thrown around
in the community is bitcoin is sound
money and
it is and nobody's necessarily arguing
well there are people but i don't think
you and i arguing that um
yeah yeah
but i don't think you and i are arguing
that like if this sounds money and it's
gonna you know be the the global reserve
currency it's just not about that but um
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
markets because today it's a little bit
of a red day
um
welcome to we're at because it moves so
fast you know i i need to check i
haven't checked you need to check
okay well we're at 48k it didn't hold
50. um
everything seems to be relatively down
today um do you have a strategy going on
or are you just like a long-term holder
like are you going to like
when do you think this bull market is
going to end are you going to cash out
to stable coins or
yeah so i am
i'm not a trader i and this is adjacent
zombies sometimes for
you at the top you should if you're a
regular person not rich and [ __ ] like
jason
selling some will probably impact your
life i'm not saying sell all but i have
never sold
anything i haven't sold anything
anything yet so
the notion that um
you know i'm like not a bitcoin
long-term holder it's just not true
because i i am i've for since it being
i've held everything i've never sold
anything
um but i think you know a lot of people
think i feel smarter than me think the
top of the cycle is going to be the end
of this quarter potentially to start
quarter one 2022
um and yes i don't see why
you can't take some profits
um
and you know maybe listen here's what i
argue too here's what i argued to jason
yesterday i said for some people in the
middle class
if they bought a cheap we'll say i
bought a five thousand dollar multiple
five thousand bitcoins um when it went
march
if it goes up to what a lot of people
think it is uh 200k right
if if i sell
20 percent of my supply
mm-hmm
that's probably not changing money to a
lot of people so they change their life
they still have 80 they're not selling
so if it doesn't go down right because
there isn't we've had this cyclical
nature of bitcoin if it doesn't go down
they still hold 80 percent it goes it
goes to the moon like he says go to a
million dollars great now they have 80
percent of the supply that's worth now a
million dollars which is started at five
which is 200x okay
if
if it goes back down right if we see a
50 60 retracement
now they can spend that 20 that they
sold they can spend uh and buy you know
2x 3x of what they would have held
and if it doesn't it goes to the moon
and they're still happy like both both
win so i just i don't see that viewpoint
i think he's maybe been been rich too
long
all my friends have a mortgage and if
yeah i understand
at age 35 or 36 that would be
life-changing to a lot of my friends
and so like how he doesn't see that
viewpoint um i i just i think some of
these people either they're they're two
bitcoin maximalists which whatever i
surprised to love them uh or they're too
rich and they just don't they don't see
that point
or i think an alternative thing is like
i think it's just like a branding thing
to just you know publicly constantly say
that they'll hold forever and the thing
is i can totally understand
taking profit if you need to like i get
that you're taking profit into like a
shitty system which once you've taken
that profit the money will devalue but
if you directly i'm going to spend it on
something whether it's like paying off a
mortgage or if it's you know i don't
know buying your children some stuff
because you can't pay for things in
bitcoin yet um and you don't have
anything and you need to buy your kids
some food you know yeah
yeah
i'm not gonna say hey listen take your
profit and go buy a fancy car
i wouldn't use it don't do that i'll
agree i want to pay your mortgage off or
you know even for some people let's say
here let's take this example say they
sell one bitcoin at let's say it gets a
200 grand okay
they want to change out to a stable coin
and they want to go on block five uh and
get i think what do you get eight
percent and i'm doing an advertisement
for block five they're not paid
black fight you should be paid me for
this um
they get i can do it they pay me it's
fine it's eight point six
eight percent okay so on the short
thousand they're gonna make 16 grand a
year like listen
for some people uh that's what 1200
extra dollars a month
that that's gonna be really nice that's
going to change their life just having
1200 extra months is coming in
so i yeah for middle class lower class
people uh it could definitely be
life-changing stuff
yeah i think there isn't kind of one
rule for all and that's like the
narrative that's pushed in the space and
i think it's quite dangerous to be
honest um because
when the ball run was going on on
clubhouse i was on clubhouse quite a lot
and unfortunately um
the narrative and the advice genuinely
the financial advice that was being said
was just smash by just smash by
like we're in the top we're at the top
of a bull market it's like 50k we're
telling these people who you don't know
you don't know their financial situation
to smash by despite bitcoin potentially
crashing down to 20k i mean
some of the advice
yeah i i agree fully unless i would
never ever say sell your whole supply
but if if vic you own bitcoin and it
goes up and the money is going to be
life-changing to you right and
everyone's in a different financial
situation um then then why not sell why
not sell a little bit um
and i just i i
can't see the argument to that and
obviously some people on bitcoin are
very wealthy
but some people aren't right and so if
they can change their life change their
lives
100 like i'm definitely for holding
money in a stable coin and earning
interest on that you know if you can't
wait
for another cycle and if you can't wait
another four years
um
but this week we've also seen some crazy
crazy weird things did you see visa
bought a crypto punk
no i didn't see that where was that yeah
so visa bought a crypto punk have over
in here for 150 000 i'm gonna say
dollars probably it's not gonna be
pounds is that um
what do you think do you are you buying
any crypto punks
i listen i i did an nfp
oh you did what did you do well uh i did
one of my for my of myself
um i did it in april um
because i knew people like jason loves
them who i do the podcast with yeah he
loved it i listen i was i was never an
artwork collector
um
so maybe that's why i don't get it i
don't i don't understand the i really
don't understand the nft thing um i know
a rich people hold money and artwork i
get that what they're gonna do in nfts
i guess it's cool if you're into that
thing i'm just i'm not super into it
i think it i mean okay so i also find it
a little bit strange especially um
the whole copy paste side of things um
like bitcoin solves the double spend
problem this obviously doesn't affect
that um
you know the copy paste thing just
throws me but i definitely see value in
kind of like digitizing
stuff giving it uh you know whether it's
like uh rolexes handbags just to
authenticate it authenticate where it
came from you know it's history that
always gives it value
um
but i think it's like anything right
like everything in the end goes digital
whether it's like
art digital real estate which people are
talking about now
um
maybe you should buy i might buy
i'll just buy i mean i so i don't like
it i don't fully understand it i don't
get the value so i might as well just
buy bitcoin which is something i
understand a whole lot more so i'll just
they can own the nfts i'll just keep
buying bitcoin
no i'm with you you shouldn't buy into
things which which you don't fully get
but i know i think i think it's a space
which isn't going to die down i actually
heard that facebook
um are now going to get into nfts that
was a bit late
really
yeah facebook's been flirting with
crypto for forever it feels like i mean
uh oh my gosh what was the name of their
wallet i mean this is back in 20 what
2018. they had libra yeah so they had
libra yes but never really it kind of
happened but not really happened um and
you've been thinking they were going to
get in forever and they haven't the
other one that i'm really interested to
see what happens is apple has all of
that extra cash sitting around so you
got to think at some point michael
sayler is going to get into their brain
and have them buy some bitcoin
do you think they will
they
at the rate the dollars devaluing it's
uh it would be shocking if they didn't
diversify because they have such a large
cash supply
and i also had um i just wanted like
another thing that i had so i'm just
going through so many different news
points that have come up um
so
deloitte did you see this they did this
survey
this survey about um covering a bunch of
different financial institutions and
they discovered that 76 percent of
financial professionals think that a
basket of cryptos like bitcoin
xrp
ada
will replace the us dollar in at least
under 10 years is this just like wishful
thinking yes i did see uh that article
um
10 years feels fast 10 years feels very
i mean who knows all right now when
and honestly because on a spectrum 10
years ago was essentially right or give
or take a year or two is that yeah
bitcoin and that seems like
eons ago i mean it really does seem like
so long ago so i guess things aren't
moving very quickly but then again
there's so much power wrapped up in the
ability to make currency um it doesn't
feel like the world governments are
going to want to give that up so i think
maybe you know we see someone like el
salvador who did it a few other
countries start going that direction
because obviously bitcoin is
not devaluing at all whereas the dollar
is and so if they can hold the bitcoin
as a reserve currency maybe then you
know i think it's essentially it is game
theory right because then once some
countries do it and other countries have
to kind of follow suit otherwise there
will be winners and losers um but tenure
still feels i don't know why that feels
like too fast who knows maybe i could be
wrong
yeah i mean the interesting thing about
this entire space is like so much has
happened
no well so much but so little has
happened in 10 years in that
institutions are now jumping into
bitcoin countries are accepting it
but i sort of feel that
it won't be as long i think more will
happen in the next 10 years do you know
what i mean because now like once it
happens what it wants faster than 10
years
say that again you think it's going to
happen faster than 10 years that bitcoin
will be a world reserve currency
okay so okay so the thing is i think
that that is a huge jump
and i don't know whether that will
happen in 10 years necessarily but i
think the growth will be faster than
what we saw in the last 10 years just
given how far how quickly it's already
happened and how far we are i don't
think you know a lot of those 10 years
were all about
legitimacy proving bitcoin having to
prove itself now it's proved itself the
next 10 years could be much faster
yeah i mean it's possible i i
yeah i just have a hard time seeing
people who have power wanting to give up
power uh that that's always a struggle
so uh let's go bitcoin but i man i i'm i
if you gave me an over under bet here
right now i would bet the over
really
yeah
okay we'll have to pick this up but um
well i think it'll happen i'm just gonna
bet the over
no fair enough but in terms of your
price you always ask um people on your
show for price predictions so i'm
obviously gonna have to have to throw
that back at you
sure
uh i i would definitely say
it's going to be
uh
it's gonna be six figures um
i'm starting so i listen i listen to two
people as far as price action and
trading is concerned although you don't
trade and that's nicholas myrna datadash
and scott milker the wolf of all streets
i really enjoy both of them um and
nicholas mer's been pushing this it's
going to be so most people think top of
this cycle is quarter four of this year
nicholas martin's also pushing this
theory that it might be a longer cycle
so the the top of the cycle might
stretch into
2022 somewhere
um
and it kind of feels like that's a
possibility now right because we had the
huge rush up uh in the early part of
this year um and then we kind of
plateaued for a minute there and then we
had the dip and then we chopped sideways
for a while and now we've been steadily
climbing up but it hasn't been like this
parabolic move it's been like it just
climbs and climbs and climbs
and so
i could definitely see the top not going
until 2022 sometime
um so i am gonna say it's gonna be six
figures by the end of the year but okay
like just just over um somewhere which i
i would probably if we talked to
crippled people i would probably be on
the low end of most people's guesses you
know like john kim my co-host is saying
250k
uh that's the high end
that's the high end
yeah you think yes well i've heard
people say more i've heard people say
other things that are even more uh but
that jason what'd he say i think he
thinks 200k by i want to say he said
october 27th i think he did say october
27th i don't know what number yeah i
don't know what number yeah so um
well what do you say
i'm obviously i don't i don't feel
comfortable making price predictions i
will say 36 figures by the end of the
year um
i don't think it's gonna be much over
that i'm gonna go like kind of on the
nicholas merton line of thought and say
that it happens sometime
next year where it fully peaks out
yeah i'm with you i think
six figures by the end of the year
apparently there'll be a big dump in
september
wait who said that and then
it says so many people really why what
so what's their reasoning
because it's they say that there's going
to be a run-up and then naturally
there'll be a huge correction and then
one last spike um
i don't know it it's all just
speculation but if if jason's right in
that 20 in the 27th of october then it
makes sense to have a bit of a
correction beforehand um
but yeah i'm so excited for this um i'm
trying to get more people involved it's
it's so difficult and it surprises me
how difficult it is um because you feel
like we're talking when we start this
conversation we're talking about like
negative interest rates and it always
blows my mind you know and i'm like guys
you're leaving your money and in
accounts which make nothing but um
there's so many people who don't don't
even wanna they don't even wanna think
about it is i think that's the biggest
issue right
oh i'm
don't want to think about it uh they
would rather just kind of do whatever
they're doing on an everyday basis they
would much rather watch if they're a
male probably some type of sporting
event they're a female some type of
reality show i know i'm generalizing
don't cancel me for that
okay it's totally okay
um yeah rather than think about like and
you know i brought this up on the
podcast yesterday with john
i can't remember what point he was
making about bitcoin changing his life
and
i said to him one of the things that's
really made me think about which i i
never really thought all that much about
it previously you know hey i
i was what
31 or 32 when i got into bitcoin um
so what i mean it's like there's number
one great a lot of grifters so i think
the banks are grifters jimmy song makes
this point in his book where they're
just pulling money off the top um in all
different kinds of ways
and now bitcoin and crypto allows us to
exchange
like i could send you i think i just saw
someone sent 150 billion dollars for
four dollars
um what price
i just have to finance finance thank you
yeah and so like that can happen right
um yeah if i want to send you cash to
the bank it's gonna take
like three days or four days and it's
gonna take 40 bucks or something like
that to send a thousand dollars um so
just inefficient and they're grifting
and so that's one of the huge things
that i think i've been paying attention
to since i got into crypto and
the the other one is just oh he went i'm
still here i'm here
uh the other thing is just
the
uh
the moral hazard of countries being able
to print money i mean it's really not
good it just it incentivizes all types
of bad behavior again i guess i'm kind
of i've read you guys should read it
jimmy song's book um thank god for
bitcoin um i'm referencing a couple
times here but just to be it's a moral
hazard to be able to print as much money
as you want and a lot of people would
even argue that wars wouldn't happen the
way they happened if countries couldn't
just print and print and have the
capacity to do so
yeah it's so interesting um
all the bad um habits
that printing money incentivizes you
know even as simple as
saving money
like literally like what is the point
what is the point if it's gonna be worth
less tomorrow and i think what is such a
shame is that
okay here's my thing i find it
you don't learn about finance in school
like you don't learn how to invest in
the stock market um like i only because
of crypto do i understand the stock
market
but i learned crypto first um and
i don't know what i would have done like
what would i have done i have no idea
you know what would i've invested in my
money would have just melted away um i
was making money when i was like 16 so
you know i have enough to want to make
sure it doesn't lose value
and so for me i i'm just so grateful
for bitcoin and just all the
opportunities for me i also say that i
kind of compare it to the american dream
like i know some people say the american
dream is dead
but i feel it doesn't have to be dead
and it isn't necessarily dead because
this is an entirely new market um with
so much opportunity whether it's just to
make money by investing or trading but
also in terms of jobs and
there are so many things for example
check this out okay let's just say you
were doing a fight they say you're doing
a fight and um say you were fighting in
london
i used to work for a local london
television channel and they probably
that was when i was 21
they probably wouldn't have let me
interview you
because i wasn't i don't know old enough
or experienced enough
do you know what i mean there's like
hierarchies they probably wouldn't have
left me whereas like i don't [ __ ]
work there anymore i haven't worked
there in years
and like now you and i can just have a
chat
and yeah that's for me
yeah
no i i i love that thought process of
like um
and i saw my man i'm getting all kinds
of book recommendations another book
that was just recommended by my co-host
jason williams was the sovereign
individual have you read that one yet
i haven't but a friend of mine just read
it and i didn't hear the best responses
um they said it was too focused on like
um the problem with money rather than
bitcoin's day-to-day application and
cryptocurrencies day-to-day application
like how it can improve your life that's
what my friend told me i'll still give
it a read well the sovereign individuals
written in the in the
mid 90s i believe yeah it does kind of
describe what bitcoin is going to be but
i mean to me what it really describes uh
and i guess the whole point of the
premise of the book is that there will
be an end of the nation state at some
point because they're not providing us
the value that we're paying that right
so what we're paying them in taxes
they're not providing us equal value
back
um and that people will kind of be more
people will be doing their own thing and
bitcoin is going to allow us to do that
because we can just exchange currency
between you and i we don't have to go
through uh you know intermediary of the
bank um and then obviously you know like
it kind of also goes to the point of um
what happened on only fans the other day
oh my god
my life um but at the same point if
people want to have
those type of things for a living they
can do those type of things and the bank
or the payment process is saying no you
can't do that right but with bitcoin
that fixes that is people can exchange
money and that's the thing with all
these you know people are coming with
the central bank digital currencies and
the government and wallets and then they
can
you know stop spending if you are
who the hell was talking about yesterday
i was listening to someone i said yeah
if someone has a
certain bmi they can block their
transactions at fast food restaurants or
something like that yes you can you can
with those and so just yeah so i guess
i'm just going rifting on your point
about um having more freedom uh i love
freedom so more freedom between it for
individuals to do what they want
so i wasn't gonna ask you about this but
like you don't have to go into it um but
what
what's really interesting
and what i find in the cryptocurrency
industry particularly within the bitcoin
movement is everybody's got this um got
very strong libertarian undertones you
know freedom autonomy and we're always
talking about this bitcoin citadel
um and i just read before we've gone
live so i'm sure
i will get some awful notifications i
was just dealing with some trolls um but
delta airlines um have said that i'll
buy your post yes
their unvaccinated employees will have
to pay two hundred dollars
i mean
i i just wonder like there
is that what they're doing i don't know
how they're gonna do it but yeah
essentially i don't know whether they'd
get paid the full amount then they have
to pay it back i don't know whether
that's even legal because basically
that's medical discrimination but that's
happening anyway
but what
does it i mean how would so i guess my
question was how does delta even have
access because aren't there hipaa laws
which would prevent the company from
accessing your personal health
information
yo you would think that's the case
except as time has gone on more
companies are saying you can't work here
unless you're vaccinated so apparently
those human rights protections are no
longer in place i i don't know how
companies are getting away with it
honestly um
but i i wondered you know
whether you think given i think it kind
of goes hand in hand
money printing inflation
lockdowns
stimulus checks the whole thing for me
personally goes hand in hand i wonder
whether you thought we'd get to a point
where
we do break off you know like the
bitcoin citadel rises
uh
yeah i
i definitely see that as a possibility
um and as i read the sovereign
individual
it feels
not like an if but a when and so
the simulator talks about you know the
transition so they talked about you know
um from how the church kind of ruled
everything for a long time to the
transition to the nation states the
nation state in its current incarnation
has been around somewhere around 500
years um and that we're going to move on
to another phase uh which the nation
state goes away because they don't
provide the value so man i do think
that's going to happen uh the
bitcoin citadel thing
yeah i have a hard time with that
because if a major world power
really
didn't want that to exist
i feel like they could somehow make that
not exist at this point in time right
you know it's some type of military
intervention um obviously you can't
confiscate people's bitcoin because
it can be memorized
i lost it i'm sorry i don't have it
anymore that you know i can't access
that so they can't actually steal your
bitcoin but they could you know if that
nation state uh say el salvador right if
they become sort of a bitcoin citadel
there could be some type of military
intervention to change the government or
whatever um so
i mean i would love for something like
that to happen because you what you what
you would have was a whole bunch of
like-minded people in this place who
want to live their lives the same way
so i don't want to say it would be kind
of utopian but it feels like that but it
also feels like there's no way that's
going to know maybe it's florida and
texas because
they're starting to drift further and
further away from
the union yeah i think it is i think the
whole
i think
how life tends to work is that it's
never quite how you imagine so the
citadel will never be quite how we
imagined but i i think it could turn out
to be florida and texas i mean i think
this conference i heard i mean
i mean i know this isn't like definite
at all but i keep hearing conversation
of like florida breaking away from the
united states um but i mean
yeah i don't think that's serious at
this point but yeah i mean
the way it's going it's
i mean i say if florida today said we're
breaking away and we're acting uh and
the united states kept on the direction
it is like i would have to very strongly
consider moving to florida or texas it's
hard it would be very hard because i
have my wrestling academies i wouldn't
be able to move those with me uh but if
we keep down the path that we're on uh
less freedom being poor printing more
money obviously those are all things
that i don't really like
and do the do
your
like wrestling
colleagues i feel like i'm not using the
correct words um wrestling colleagues is
that is that well i have uh so obviously
i have
well i have the people i coach with
would be more like colleagues right
yeah and then i have you know the
wrestlers which i try
as much as possible
they're 1800 most of them should never
to get into politics or that type of
stuff with them uh i try never to
discuss that because i don't need to be
influenced that's what their parents are
for
uh
their parents but i'm not gonna talk to
them about governmental decisions and
whatnot um but yeah for my colleagues
they they all know how i feel most of
them are like-minded that's why we work
together
um
yes they feel similarly
that's cool so so where are you where
are you right now you're on holiday
uh we're i'm in northern wisconsin so
wisconsin's estate um
it's so we were about four hours so it's
way up here there's just a bunch of
trees and lakes and not much else
um i'm actually i don't know if you ever
heard of disc golf but there's a disc
golf course right here so it's it's a
great game i love it um so i get to go
and play every day and then we go to the
beach and we hang out and we do that
type of thing so it's really good oh my
god that's the american dream i'm
telling you so
what what what are your final words
where can people follow you what are you
up to um just show yourself for us ben
just it's just at ben askren everywhere
uh twitter instagram i don't really love
instagram i post it a little bit but i
enjoy twitter i enjoy the back and forth
i enjoy the banter i enjoy reading other
people's opinions and thoughts i think
it's where the smartest uh dialogue
happens of any social media
and dumbest
no
it's a great club
yeah i dare you to go read some
instagram comments and tell me twitter's
the dumbest
read those instagram comments and you're
like how is anyone above 13 year old in
these comments
it literally sounds like my
three-year-old um
yeah yeah so then we do the funky crypto
podcast on tuesdays with jason i love
your podcast by the way i watch it all
the time guys you need to watch that
podcast it's so funny
you guys are just so ridiculous um i
really enjoy it so
has added to the ridiculousness factor
because for he is very highly
intelligent but he is very goofy also
yeah no i think it's brilliant i think
it's a great mix i think that's how
people should be i hate people that are
over that are super successful but are
so serious and you just can't have fun
with them that's
that's never the way
yeah but then
we'll have you on once your book drops
and we all read it we will
have to come back on and talk about it
and then i'm actually going to be in
texas in uh
september too so i know you i saw you
said that on twitter somewhere as well
yeah i will be yeah let me know it's
probably looking like october at this
point but let me know i'll be in texas
thank you so much for coming on
say that sorry i keep i keep
interrupting you ben what did you say
i said austin city austin texas one of
the greatest cities in america you're
gonna enjoy it is it or dallas
i like i prefer austin
okay i heard it's full of loads of
liberals that's what i heard but
uh it's it you know what i so i i
obviously uh sorry we're trying to end
the show and i'm talking no go for it
it's fine just go for it you know what i
i am like socially liberal like i don't
yeah
a lot of things but
in other ways i'm conservative and so i
think austin has that good mix of
there's certain liberal qualities to it
okay
like the texas conservative feeling as
well so i really enjoy austin a lot
what about miami just last thought is it
good
i haven't been to miami in a long time
but after i was so jealous i did not go
to the bitcoin convention
i had something else planned it was
really stupid i should have went um so
it looked it looks so awesome
yeah i hope to go to the next one
that's the goal
all right enjoy the rest of your holiday
thanks so much for coming on i'm excited
to come on to yours guys follow ben
check out his podcast it's actually
hilarious um and yeah that's it guys
thanks so much for watching and i will
see you all next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]